could you could you sketch what's wrong
from your perspective with subjective
rights right you are one of the sharpest
critics it from theological circles in
the Christian theological circles of
subjective rights that are kind of
underpin whole liberal democracies
that's it that's a huge challenge right
and so it may be helpful if you would if
you would sketch in a few points what is
what you see as a problem with that and
maybe that's going to generate our
discussion I know that we've read some
of that but but if you can maybe remind
us of it I'll be helpful
well I think and they most generally
speaking they they they they place the
focus wrongly in trying to understand
human community
what theologically speaking of is
referred to as moral community that is
to say the whole community of human
goods and lights I'm not using the term
oil in any narrow sense I think they
misplaced the focus it ought to be on
human relationships with God and with
one another and not on individuals that
is the first point the the the stemming
from that is the question well why this
focus on the individual and as I made
I've made this point of course in my in
my interpretation of the history of
Western rights and again today that I
think that focus has been the beginning
had an interest in seeing human freedom
that is to say this the the capacity of
human beings to choose to do one thing
rather than another to make one moral
judgment rather than another one
judgment of another that very capacity
has been seen as the an originating
right on which all other human rights
based erected the foundation of the
building of human rights and that is the
case I think from the Canlis
onward that is not simply part of one
might say the Lockean Hobbesian project
that the later project and the
understanding is the individual as a
proprietor someone who both are who
governs him or herself precisely because
they own their capacities and spiritual
resources and they own their acts in a
sense they make their act and they have
a proprietary control to dispose of the
proprietary right to dispose of
themselves and at their acts as they
they wish to this this is a conception
which implicit and and drawn-out has
accompanied the path of Western human
rights are more or less from the
beginning in various stages of its of
explicitness and elaboration and that it
seems to me runs clean contrary to an
understanding of human beings as
essentially oriented in their their
communal and individual lives to their
relationship to God that end to to their
neighbors their relationship to God
being one as I indicated a few months
ago being one primarily of of adoration
love gratitude reverence and openness
and obedience in the sense of openness
to divine the Divine Will as it reveals
itself both in our natural perceptions
of right and also as revealed to
Christians in Scripture
so the main point really is about the
misplaced focus and from there one can
go on to to a spectrum of theological
and philosophical criticisms